Speaker 1: Let's go next to Aiden from
Alberta. Aiden, welcome to the program.
Aiden from Alberta. Aiden. I'm guessing
you have the wrong audio device selected.
Speaker 3: Hello? I got it. You guys okay? I'll
make it quick, since I wasted all the time there.
Please. No. Charlie Crist. Very good last night,
in my opinion. Oh, yeah. And one of the things I
noticed is he used some common Republican talking
points against DeSantis. Specifically, though, the
gas prices. I noticed he attacked DeSantis
on the gas prices thing. Yeah. Which I was
wondering if you think Democrats should do that
more using those more kind of political arguments
that the Republicans use against themselves.
Speaker 1: Listen, I am not going to tell anybody
to stop using whatever works. Against terrible
people like Ron DeSantis. So if Charlie Crist
saying, listen, you want to talk about the Biden
gas prices, it's the DeSantis gas prices. They're
off the charts here in Florida. If that works.
Use it. You know, there's nothing immoral about
that. You're not shooting anyone. You're
not defrauding anyone. You're just really
strategically choosing who to blame for
something that's really a national phenomenon.
In my heart of hearts, I don't think Biden
nor DeSantis have much to do with gas prices,
as I've said before. But it's the type of thing
where I would say, if it works, absolutely do it.
Speaker 3: Yeah. No, I completely
agree. And. Yeah. Thank you. Have
a. Have a good rest of your show today.
Speaker 1: All right, Aiden from Alberta,
great to hear from you. Let's go next
to Jasper from Brazil. Jasper, welcome.
Speaker 3: Hi, David. How's it going?
Speaker 1: It's going well.
Speaker 3: So I wanted to ask you. I
see countries like Argentina and Brazil,
where I'm currently living, trying the same sorts
of protectionist trade strategies over and over
again, particularly when led by populist leftist
leaders. And they often don't work to grow. The
local economy have the opposite effect to sink
the local currency. Do you think the left has
some sort of populist trade policy problem?
Speaker 1: So when it comes to populism,
I don't see populism really as being policy.
I see populism as being a rhetoric and a
messaging strategy. So I would not say that
there's a left populism trade policy problem,
because I don't think populism by definition is
policy. Now as applied to Argentina specifically,
it's been one disastrous decision after another
after another. By every administration it's
been Cristina, Alberto, Macri. It's
been just disastrous all the way down.
And. It is also true that the current debt
situation, which is absolutely related to the IMF
and World Bank history with Argentina and we can't
say that there is no responsibility or blame,
there is also completely untenable that I
don't know that you're even going to trade
your way out of the problem anyway. So anybody
who like the thing that will happen is depending
on which hammer you have, or maybe better said,
depending on whether you have a hammer or a drill,
you see everything as either a nail or a screw.
In terms of saying the problem has been Cristina
and Alberto and others say, No, no, no, no,
no, no. The problem has been Macri. No, no,
no. The problem has been the IMF. It is decades of
bad decisions upon bad decisions by bad leaders,
and there's no one thing to blame. But no, I
don't think it's a populism policy problem, since
populism isn't really a policy, it's a rhetoric.
Speaker 3: Okay. Thanks. They also ask you another
question about Bolsonaro. The election
is coming up on, I believe, Saturday.
Speaker 1: Sunday, or is it
Saturday? No, it's Sunday.
Speaker 3: Okay. Sunday, yeah. Yeah. And he seems
pretty dangerous and it looks like he has a very
good chance to win. What do you think could happen
in the next sort of four years here in Brazil?
Speaker 1: I would defer to the real experts on
Brazilian politics. I agree with you. He clearly
has a shot to win. But I would ask someone
who is following the Brazilian situation
more closely. It doesn't make sense for
me to be the person opining on that.
Speaker 3: Okay. Fair. Thank
you. All right. My pleasure.
Speaker 1: There is Jasper from Brazil
with a very, very interesting question.